salut aujourd'hui comme promis je
réponds à vos questions voici donc la
première faq et mentale vlog je suis
super étonné je pensais pas avoir autant
de questions en fait à vrai dire je
pensais en avoir peut-être une vingtaine
ou un truc comme ça il ya une plus d'une
centaine de questions qui ont été posées
entre celle sur youtube celle sur
twitter sur facebook sur snapshot vous
m'avez snap et des questions fait drôle
du coup c'est des questions très court
bref il y en a eu deux partout alors
j'ai essayé d'en réunir celles qui
représentait un petit peu 1-1 en sang
j'ai lu des questions délégués de classe
je retrousse les manches c'est parti
pour la faq ton cet homme vidéo comment
t'y prends tu pour réaliser des blogs
giornetti pour toi c'est quoi
- cette vidéo bas il est pas très
compliqué j'ai une canon legria minix
celle qu'on a tous je crois que c'est le
cas pierre cros celle caterino c'est le
cas kyan khojandi gelé depuis quelques
années aussi allé très pratique pour
l'emmener partout j'ai aussi une go pro
c'est celle que je me mets soit sur moi
soit sur la personne que je mentalise
pour que vous ayez le point de vue et
comment je me prends pour réaliser mes
blogs et bien vaste question bonne part
d'improvisation mais sinon je gratte des
idées en fait j'ai des carnets comme
ceux ci où je marque mes idées
directrices et puis je vais piocher
dedans
d'un point de vue général j'ai toujours
ma caméra sur moi si je croise un pote
les baisses je lui fais un mental blog
parce que j'ai pas le temps une par jour
j'ai pas le temps d'attendre et une
journée type pour toi c'est quoi ces
galères je me lève beaucoup trop tôt
vous allez vous moquez de moi c'est sûr
mais c'est tellement sûr je me lève
maintenant à 8h 8h30 du matin
mais avant le mail ne fait jamais la
star si ça fait un peu plus tard quand
même tu vois et puis pas tous les jours
surtout pas j'ai pas trouvé mon rythme
de croisière que même le dimanche je me
lève il faut il faut que je m'organise
j'ai déjà 10 à 12 du vo d'ailleurs faux
je n'organise c'est clair la journée
type pour moi c'est surtout de faire en
sorte que le blog ne prennent pas toute
la journée turin mais on va dire
qu'entre le fait d'écrire une idée je
fais de gratter un peu de textes de
tourner et de monter d'habiller le
montage de mettre sur youtube de la
partager l'ensemble ça donne prendre
entre deux et trois heures quand ça me
prend deux heures c'est bien deuxième
question faut pas que je souffre aussi
long à chaque question la fin du 2 3
heures pourtant faq qu'est ce qui t'a
encouragés à faire ce défi est ce que tu
trouves du temps pour souffler mon
passage a répondu ah ça non je ne trouve
pas de temps pour souffler et ce qui m'a
encouragé à faire ce défi le fait que ce
soit un défi en fait trop en tout cas
pour moi tu sais si tu regardes la
première vidéo c'est ça s'est passé
comme je t'ai dit en fait loi
o qui motive à faire des vidéos il ya
jeanne qui m'a fait découvrir le format
vlog une fois que j'investis tu es en
tête elle m'a plus quittée en fait je
pensais qu'à ça donc
donc j'ai pas si ça m'a encouragé mais
en tout cas un moment donné a fallu que
je le fasse
notez les questions fin mesure parce que
sinon quand je le monte je vais galérer
et comme il faut que je publie la vidéo
dans une heure et demie ça te fait quoi
de savoir que j'ai fait a fait quoi que
deux heures que j'étais enfin démasqué
que j'ai trouvé l'armé ultime pour
mettre fin à son règne
jeanne
c'est une des premières vidéos
d'ailleurs que j'ai fait je les
mentalités en vidéo et elle a fait une
vidéo sur moi en fait où elle se sent
persécuté
elle fait un peu peur d'ailleurs dans
cette vidéo je vous mettrai le lien
quelque part sous la lune descriptif
soit soit par ici autour de moi la
trouvait apparemment sains selon elle
une arme pour pas que je puisse vous
mentaliser est ce que ça marche
je me demandais comment tu feras quand
tu vas faire la fête un jour par exemple
ton anniversaire pour poster une vidéo
au site a fait voeu de chasteté de la
fiesta alors déjà non j'ai pas fait voeu
de chasteté de la fiesta
je vais te dire même quelque chose n'est
pas fait voeu de chasteté de vacances
alors je sais pas comment je vais faire
mais je veux le faire
en fait ça s'est déjà passé une fois
c'était le lendemain de l'européen avec
laminé scadd le vendredi soir j'étais
avec la mine s'est couché tard on a un
peu picolé et où quand je suis rentré
j'ai pas eu le courage de monter la
vidéo et bien demain on était samedi et
la vidéo elle doit être en ligne à 11
heures donc je me suis levé en fait pour
l'instant à part me levais je vois pas
d'autre solution
bon anniversaire grand fou ça veut dire
quoi vlog guizhou ah oui donc marine
on part de loin marine blog c'est une
contraction entre entre blogs et vidéos
c'est pavés ou lg en fait ça ça veut
dire de spécial
vouloir c'est à dire vidéo longue ou
olic arjen anam question serait est-ce
que tu as beaucoup d'idées encore pour
tvh loeb des trucs originaux je prends
très mal sa question ça veut dire que tu
trouves que c'est pas original ce que je
fais je te réponds par salut j'adore tu
achètes ton spitaels ou là alors donc je
vais te la lire pour de vrai j'ai remis
cela j'adore ta chaine ton spectacle je
t'ai vu à l'union on avait parlé vite
faith hâte de te revois ma question
comment as tu eu tu envie de devenir
mentalist en fait j'ai pas vraiment eu
envie de devenir mentalist j'ai
découvert le mentalisme avec les choses
auxquelles je m'intéressais au départ à
savoir la magie les choses sur la
mémoire les choses sur la psychologie et
un jour j'ai trouvé qu'ils avaient un
nom quand globe et tout ça qui
s'appelait le mentalisme voilà comment
j'ai dit en vie est ce que ma réponse de
vàd ça te fait quoi de savoir que tu
bousille la vie des gens après les avoir
mentaliser poèmes de jeanne c'est que
des fois il fait peur crois que j'ai un
petit peu traumatisé jeunes bravo pour
tes vidéos pour la foire aux questions
dit ce qui t'a donné envie d'exercer ce
métier à part banni le petit toutou as
tu d'autres animaux oui ça m'intéresse
oui j'ai d'autres animaux j'ai un chat
il s'appelle thomas l'eau est déjà dans
une des vidéos
fabien olicard de mentalist en vidéo
c'est les vidéos que je faisais avant de
lancer ce blog par moi donc tu peux le
voir je crois c'est dans la vidéo 3 4 5
ou 6 me fourchette un petit peu large et
tu peux aussi voir tu as mal aux dents
le récap numéro 4 que j'ai mis ce
dimanche-là sur facebook et sur youtube
il est ici c'est d'ailleurs sa place
préférée c'est à dire que quand je
travaille moi sur mon bureau il se mêle
à pascal radiateur et donc qui se moque
ici et il dort là il me fous des poils
partout et ce qui est magnifique c'est
qu'il aime bien des petits endroits
chauds donc ils aiment bien mon mac
parce que mon mac il est chaud et se
posent dessus ils envoient des mails
il est des commentaires ça ne veut rien
dire si encore c'était efficace et
productive quelle est la différence
entre un pigeon du verre une question
pourquoi ce jeu de mots alors si tu
parles de l'homme qui parlait à
l'oreille des cheveux bon et que tu vois
pas où est le jeu de mots c'est que le
cinéma t'intéresse pas tellement
tellement par contre j'aurais dû mettre
murmuré au lieu de parler mais comme
murmuré c'était beaucoup trop gros et sa
rentrée face à me saouler et donc je
suis jeune homme qui parlait à l'oreille
des cheveux et si tu parles du type
pourquoi le x files des coupes de
cheveux
je t'avoue que je sais j'en sais rien du
tout en fait depuis tout à l'heure je
regarde ça et je me disais oui à la
raison pourquoi j'ai appelé ça le hic
seuil des coupes de cheveux de y avoir
un truc derrière je devais avoir une
idée au départ et j'ai dû avoir un début
d'idée je suis pas allé au bout et je
sais plus c'est plus du tout pourquoi
israël détenait enfin fabien sait pas
quand il faut que je mette des titres et
des descriptifs aussi tous les jours ça
c'est ça c'est une tuerie en fait à
chaque fois tirs qu'est ce que je vais
mettre et où j'ai dû avoir une idée je
ne sais pas tu désolé salomé déjà encore
bravo tu es vidéo son génial merci
mais sinon je voulais savoir si tu
pouvais mentaliser mon banquier bien sûr
il faut que je sache un peu
ton numéro de compte et une étude
graphologique aussi serait nécessaire
donc si tu peux m'envoyer un chèque tu
le signe ça me permet d'analyser ta
signature d'analyser le numéro de compte
de voir quelles banques c est s inquiète
pas t'as pas être déçu quels sont tes
meilleurs souvenirs de la rochelle vise
damien damien larralde on était au lycée
ensemble avec damien écoute damien j'ai
trop de bons souvenirs à la rochette je
peux pas te dire qu'à l'époque il ya une
époque musicale
oui je jouais de la musique yahia il ya
trop de choses à la branche est trop
tous les divines leur retour
est-ce que tu mentale ''sera des
personnes à la rue dante et prochain
mentale blog où tu fais juste à
quasiment restée en fait je fais pas
forcément qu'avec les humoristes ça ça
devient juste du fait que ces milieu
dans lequel je travaille donc forcément
ce que je crois c'est mes collègues de
boulot ce sont les humoristes c'est pour
ça que vous en voyez beaucoup mais mais
si j'étais si j'étais comptable vous
croiser auriez des comptables dans mes
vidéos
ce serait pareil dans la rue j'aimerais
bien en fait c'est juste que c'est
compliqué à mettre en place
et comme je veux essayer de pas utiliser
plus de trois heures de ma journée pour
le mental blog j'aimerais qu'il y ait
des gens plus normaux que les humoristes
est-ce que non un humoriste et pas
quelqu'un de tout à fait normal dans sa
tête c'est du côté projets quand tu
restes le mentalist ou ta vie tu as
tenté d'apprendre de nouveaux ports par
tu en tournée avec ton nouveau spectacle
c'est quoi le titre
bisous je suis au ski dans le jura pas
de neige mais du soleil j'ai donc reçu
une carte postale de marine fougasse
bonsoir fabien giraud si ta carte de
voeux aujourd'hui qui viendrait très
plaisir la vidéo aujourd'hui était très
impressionnante haie et j'aimerais bien
avoir la même capacité de mémoire ah oui
c'était celle sur la mémoire d'accord
pour revenir tous mes cours quel jeu le
statut un peu en ce moment j'ai une
petite question pour les faq comment
avez vous fait pour déplacer la croix de
votre main à la main de rémy d'aidé
kaffrine bonne soirée alors la carte de
voeux c'est parce que j'avais envoyé les
cartes de voeux que j'avais en trop tous
ceux qui m'avaient envoyé un message les
30 premiers en tout cas cool que vous
ayez reçu c'est chouette
et alors pour la
lacroix déplacés de la main trouve ça
beau d'oser poser cette question en fait
je trouve ça beau en fait d'avoir la
naïveté de penser qu'on aura une réponse
tu dors bien la nuit fabien olicard tu
me vois plus mais moi je te vois ouais
c'est flippant un peu un g1 au bout d'un
moment si jamais il m'arrive quelque
chose ce que durant quelques jours je ne
pose plus de vidéos que vous n'avez plus
nouvelles de moi
envoyer les flics chez jeanne soumet son
adresse dans les commentaires bon
courage jeanne peuhmond était devenu
mentalist est ce un ton où sa demande
juste le travail beaucoup de travail du
travail j'ai pas de donges pas médium
cheveux en voyant chez pathé les bases
utilise des techniques en fait pour vous
bluffer pour vous faire marrer mais
c'est du travail à la limite si j'ai un
truc un peu particulier c'est que j'ai
une bonne mémoire de base
mais voilà j'ai pas j'ai pas de
capacités particulières au départ
peuvent être que tu peux situe à 20
mille abonnés présenter le prochain
numéro tout nu c'est gênant olic et pour
les 100000 je m'y engage
ben alors ça ça voudrait dire qu'on
aurait atteint les 100 milles avant la
fin de l'année
donc je prends pas trop de risques pour
les 100000 je fait un numéro tout cas
pas de problème c'est un engagement
olivier nicolau doit bien avoir des fois
où ça marche pas comment fais tu dans ce
cas là c'est vrai l'isi tout à fait il
ya des faux ça marche pas et comme vous
avez pu le voir sur la vidéo avec
joachim mon diffuseur et comme vous
allez pouvoir le voir sur une vidéo que
j'ai pas encore mise en ligne que dans
celle de demain d'ailleurs
des fois je suis un petit peu à côté
voilà et quand ça marche pas et bien je
fais quoi j'assume et je vous met la
vidéo parce que voilà c'est comme ça ça
peut arriver
elle utilise tu détruis de mentalist
dans la vie de tous les jours pour
négocier un contrat savoir quand
quelqu'un ment maintenant je sais de la
déontologie utilisait sa dé à des fins
personnelles un temps ce serait pas
serait pas bien et voilà c'était la
première et facussé télé j'ai
sélectionné vingt questions qui
représentait bien tout ce que vous
m'avez posé dessus j'espère que les
réponses vous en prie ne seront pas
écrit dans la 9 ans elles ont été
spontanées si cette vidéo vous a plu
vous propose de mettre un petit pouce en
l'air parce que ça c'est important
encore plus important ap
donnez vous à la chaîne youtube et
c'était dans le sud n'oublie pas toute
cette semaine je joue de mercredi à
dimanche à aix en provence au
café-théâtre la fontaine d'argent bien
me voir là bas on peut se rencontrer on
peut faire une vidéo ce serait vraiment
cool j'espère de voir là bas
et quoi qu'il arrive on se retrouve
demain pour le prochain mentale blog à
17 heures sur la chaîne youtube
ciao